a Kentucky man is suing the government
over a program that seizes the property
belonging to criminal suspects federal
government took nearly 29 billion
dollars worth of money and property
between 2001 and 2014 and most of it was
seized without charging anyone with a
crime Jan Crawford is on Capitol Hill
where lawmakers plan to investigate this
program Jan good morning
well good morning so civil forfeiture
was really meant to help law enforcement
go after the drug cartels we're tying
money or assets to a big cartel boss
could be difficult but now lawmakers
here on Capitol Hill say they're going
to look into cases where property is
being seized from innocent people and
some of those property owners are taking
their cases to court in 2015 rancher
gerardo serrano drove from his home in
rural kentucky to visit his cousin in
mexico as he crossed the border in Eagle
Pass Texas Serrano snapped a picture
drawing the attention of agents who
pulled him out of his truck and started
searching his vehicle the next thing I
know wanted agency we got him
he said we got him we got him like he
found something he found something and
he shows me a magazine with five bullets
in it I have a conceal and carry license
was there a gun without no Serrano a US
citizen was detained for hours for
agents informed him they would be
seizing his new Ford pickup accusing him
of transporting munitions of war across
the US border the seizure was authorized
under a program that empowers law
enforcement to take money or property
suspected of being linked to a crime
even without a conviction agencies often
use the money or auction off the
property and keep the proceeds the
federal government's forfeiture fund
increased from roughly 1 billion dollars
in 2007 to 4.5 billion in 2014 and at 26
states where records are public more
than 250 million dollars was seized in
2012 alone so asset forfeiture we're
gonna go back on after assuming office
President Trump vowed to roll back Obama
era restrictions on the program
in July Attorney General Jeff Sessions
followed through but promised more
Justice Department oversight
since then sessions has trumpeted the
program's successes taking drug dealers
money and passing it out people officers
like Montgomery County Police Chief Tom
manger argue the program shouldn't be
eliminated because of a few bad actors
we cannot just allow people who have
earned hundreds of thousands millions of
dollars through criminal activity to
keep that money so let's find a way to
do this right 25 states have passed
reforms in recent years to protect
citizens from forfeiture abuse but the
Institute for justice
still grades most protections as
below-average giving the federal
government a d-minus Robert Johnson is a
lawyer with the Institute and it's taken
on Serrano's case pro bono he says the
current federal policy provides a big
loophole you could still be pulled over
by a state police officer who says oh
gosh you have cash in your car I want to
take it and instead of forfeiting it
under state law I'm gonna transfer it to
the federal government while many
individuals admit guilt just to get
their property back Serrano who relies
on his truck for work has paid nearly
twenty thousand dollars while waiting
for his day in court
I wanted the judge to see this and I
want them at some point to stop this
policy do you ever think I'm an American
I'm an American citizen look if they
changed my government I want to know
I need the Bill of Rights if we don't
have my rights what do we got now
Customs and Border Patrol told us the
agency won't comment on pending
litigation but that its agents are
trained to follow the law but some
critics hope that Serrano's case or one
like it will someday make it to the
Supreme Court where conservatives like
Justice Clarence Thomas have signaled
opposition to the program Norah can a
really important story thank you so much